welcome to another morning show I have
got a new friend with me beyond welcome
aboard
tell us tell us quickly about what you
do my name is Deon Francis I am the
founder and the operator of blueprint
pathfinders in queer life coaching
company here in Toronto and we
specialize in identifying restoring and
helping people to preserve the natural
skill set that helps them to pretty much
reach their optimum success how do you
really get that success and not just
experiencing drizzles but really
consistently living the purposeful life
what's the opposite of gisle you're
launching a book yes I am is it who's
that we're talking about social media
strategies to lunch yes it's it's about
getting that book out there I was as I
mentioned before I came out of a legal
background social media it's not really
my thing and it's it's not my genre I'm
not necessarily as versed as you are
most people I it seems like I speak to
everyone yeah and they're versed so I
would keep on wondering where was I
while her all this has taken place but
it's about launching the book yeah and
maximizing the tools that are that are
out there to to to get the message to
the audience I think the benefit you
have is you've been doing this for years
you've helped a lot of people you have a
message and one of the most frustrating
things that I've seen is people who have
all the experience aren't aren't they
don't have the knowledge until they're
not sharing up in the platforms that are
relevant I did a interview with david
bach david bach this is sold 7 million
books financial wizard and he comes on
my channel and everybody's like who's
this guy
but it's not their fault it's his right
because he's not doing his have YouTube
he's not on Instagram and so these
people are are are fading technology is
gonna change and so we want to stay
relevant and my mom would say if you
have the ability then you have the
responsibility come on
so that's that's that's ingrained into
me deep and so you have you know you
have been a great ability and so now
let's make it the responsibility to
share it if I'm looking at the
platform's Instagram was the easiest way
to grow the fastest way to grow YouTube
is the longest is the the way to build
your brand so YouTube a video that you
make now in five years it's still gonna
be relevant and still gonna be watched
as long as a message but your message of
changes is always relevant
every generation right so it's any kind
of that evergreen content if you make a
great video now and five years people
will still be watching it with Instagram
nobody cares what happened two weeks ago
let alone five years ago it's it's
instead what it is is instant okay
Instagram is faster to grow and get an
immediate audience and traction so if
I'm looking book launch then I'm looking
Instagram first YouTube I'd be looking
at more long-form building the brain cuz
you're not done with this one book this
is your life's mission so yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna be on forever
and ever so what are we looking at is
Instagram how do I make daily content
and it's not it's not that difficult to
make a Content you're a thought leader
and so you want to teach me how you
think I want to think like you think I
want to see the world like you see the
world I want to get the perspective that
you're giving me and you see it to come
that's a different way of seeing it like
you just change someone's mind set right
so it's not all about having fancy
editing and worrying about all the
videography and everything involved in
it you you came and if you start
building a business off of the video
side you can hire editors and a team to
come in and help you but starting point
is you and your phone you
we're making this off my phone that's
the starting point whether whether you
have a tripod and you're talking into it
or whether you're just holding up the
phone mm-hmm I would look at a daily
video message from you of something that
you want to share I think video I think
you play very well on video I think you
know you know there's in front of the
camera but for most people and your
starting is like shaking right that's a
lot of a lot of people when I'm helping
them with their social media stuff is
they freeze and finally camera moves I
can see it you know I froze up my first
time I mean it's just when you start at
anything you aren't good at it right and
then you get better with practice and
repetition so you've been doing this so
I would look at how do I make a daily
message you have up to one minute to
make a video on Instagram so it's still
short so what can you say in a minute
that would touch somebody's life today
right and then you just have to write in
the caption what the theme is today's
message is whatever you can even you
could pull from your book you can pull
from you know I would be doing a
countdown like 28 days before a launch
my book today's message is change really
quick video and don't let the where most
people fall down ones that let the
editing get in the way so they filmed
that but then well it needs to be card I
need to have music behind it need to
have fancy graphics not as important for
your long-term brand building you will
get there but more important than how
fancy it is is the message that what's
the message right if I watch it and you
make me stop in my tracks and think huh
I need to change what I'm doing today
and that's it there you go there's like
wow we have and this Deon person great
like I'm gonna follow her I want I want
to dive more into her what's this book
when's it coming now right I think you
have that ability and hopefully to make
one minute video of the day takes you
know five minutes to do not four hours
of preparation it's just thinking about
what's the message that I that you feel
connected with today and what do you
want to share whether you come to it
just thinking about in the morning or
whether you think about somebody on the
bus that you've seen and their potential
and that inspires you to make a video so
one minute videos everyday the other
option you have with Instagram is what
they call stories and these expire in 24
hours where it's 15 seconds max so a
quick 15-second yeah tell you right like
what can you say in 15 seconds I'm
thinking oh wow yeah that's that's
pretty and then people are yeah it's
fast then people are going towards a
sound bite but it doesn't mean you have
to talk to the quickly get you message
just to get the words because the
emotion right if you said I want I want
you to know that you're worthy and that
you are the highest form of creation
that but Thursday and that's it and
that's it and and I think even in your
the way you talk is almost melodic you
know like there's an energy you know and
it's like you're it's like you're
singing but you're speaking it's it's
yeah it's over right for somebody who's
like you know scrolling to their phone
for little for the next you know
Instagram post you just the way you are
is already a shock compared to what most
people are doing we do think it's good
the calm relaxed melodic vibe is already
different so I've crossed that hurdle
yeah you're already ahead of the game
and that's the easiest one to do because
it's just you and your phone it's meant
to be you and the phone
yeah if you've a phone and you have a
camera on your phone you mean you see a
connection you can start making content
and I think video is the best spot for
you because you you come off so well on
video like I think I think I'm sure the
book is written very well so you can
write possibly too but like the vibe
there's a lot dismissed when you're not
when it's only written versus it is
there was an experience yeah it's an
experience an experience he's talking to
you it's totally different than if I if
I took up an article that you wrote yeah
there is something about when the spirit
or the soul connects it yeah you
experience some of the verbal
communication yeah overrides so many
things that we can read or or see there
is something about hearing a voice and
it can move you to another place it
shifted it has a that ability so it's
it's true in place to what you're really
good at mm-hmm right so the more we can
leverage your strengths the more you're
gonna win right and more importantly the
more your message is gonna reach people
and impact their lives whether it's this
book or whatever future things that I'm
sure you've got planned that are
exciting they explode I'm excited I'm
very excited about what where I am and
what I'm doing and yeah it's I'm loving
life right now I knew I didn't want the
life that I was living but I I lived it
anyway
I I lived it because you have to live it
until you figure out where exactly I'm
going and it's that's really the message
that I would love for people to to
understand you might not be in the place
where you want to be it doesn't mean
you'll never get to the place where you
are designed to be and we all have a
place that when we step into that arena
you don't eat the effort to shine or the
effort to advance succeed or find find
the peace and comfort it becomes
effortless I get up every day thinking
I'm a star and it's it's my friends will
tell you that odeon always loved herself
no I really love me now I truly believe
that the people who meet me today will
meet the Trudy on the people who have
known me had to make a journey with me
to the truth er me and I I always
believed there was more to me but I
couldn't I could not articulate it nor
was I able to translate it to life no
let's talk about getting the message
yeah out there and so something like
that you know you can make it quick
those are called stories 15 seconds I
look at 3 to 5 times a day
whenever inspir never inspiration hits
like I want you to wake up every day
know that you are a star most a good
indicator is anytime you're feeling
heightened emotion record and post
whether you're grateful whether you're
happy
whether you're frustrated and then how
do you come out of it like I'm on this
bus I thought it'd be her but you know
what I'll get there and it'll be okay
yeah right any any heightened emotion
record post and it's super easy the
mechanics aren't difficult to do I know
it may sound overwhelming cuz you don't
you know you haven't post anything yet
but it's not mechanically difficult to
go through and do so 1515 second stories
three to five times a day three to eight
times a day in that range and then a
daily one-minute video okay for YouTube
I think is a good place to be I probably
start looking at YouTube after you
launch a book because you're so tight on
the timing with the book like it's
coming out November 23 right
YouTube again takes long with the
build-up but has a much longer shelf
life so just like your book took a long
time to write but then will live forever
that strategy is a Content there will be
some things that are only relevant to a
2018-2019 environment but most of the
book is gonna be if my grandkids wanted
to see it it's still relevant longer
form works better so now I'm looking at
like how do I make him eat the 12 minute
video and can you and I think you can
this is challenge to most people how can
you sit in front of a camera for eight
to 12 minutes and continually give good
information
Facebook up down and that I've done on
Facebook live I think he would love
Instagram live once you get a few
followers happening mm-hmm so we're
we're on this again live now people are
watching us but another cool feature is
like this little comments happening down
on the side they're saying stuff when I
don't have a guest
I'll go picture-in-picture where it'll
just be me on camera
and then I can bring people in and you
see them on the screen exactly right
similar to Facebook live but it's
amazing I think you would do so well
with that because somebody would call in
and say Dion I don't know how to how to
find my path I don't know what to do and
then you you coach them really yeah
right but in that process of coaching
them and helping them other people are
watching and hopefully learning as well
and help spread your mission reaching
people as well
I go YouTube live once a week and I go
Instagram live at least five times a
week
Wow yeah this it's fine hey like having
a guest is fine this is great but but
also having people picture pretty people
calling in from all over the world and
say hey if I'm struggling with this what
do you think is it's a lot of is really
fulfilling and then other people
watching get the benefit of learning so
I think I think you would excel in that
and I think you would just enjoy it you
need to build up a bit of an audience so
that when you go live people are tuned
in watching or if you had a regular show
to say hey every day like this people
know everyday 9 o'clock Eastern we go
live join in come watch I have a special
guest coming on and I'll see what we
talked about I would probably just go
all in on Instagram if I was you right
now and then in 2019 start looking at a
YouTube strategy once you're once you've
done all the book crazy parties and -
you know there's a lot of stuff to worry
about but you two would still just be
you start off your phone Instagram is
vertical YouTube is horizontal so just
flip the phone around super complicated
but then you can film it this way just
you'll have giant black bars on the side
okay because it's meant to go horizontal
or just you know flip the phone and then
and then talk for eight to 12 minutes on
a subject whether you're channeling
somebody that you just recently work
with and you want to share that message
whether you
in a guided meditation whether you're
like whatever you would normally do if
you could spit it for 8 to 12 minutes
then those are all individual YouTube
videos if you could do that daily that's
awesome if somebody wants to like find
your book Amazon Amazon and major
bookstores and it's called change the
lies we tell ourselves and the stories
we believe we all have gone there I love
it thank you so much for coming in
appreciate you give a hug thank you so
much they let have energy if you want to
learn some more growth hacks and how to
succeed on social check interview -
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there don't move that I have and
the thing that I want to talk to you
about today and the variable of the
difference of the companies that win and
lose